und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
guten Abend Deutschland ist ein
Einwanderungsland oder was längst klar
Schienen wird plötzlich in der Debatte
über die Reform des einbürgerungsrechts
nochmal neu verhandelt die SPD
Innenministerin hat einen Entwurf
vorgelegt der umsetzt was die Ampel in
den Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben hat
ein modernes Staatsangehörigkeitsrecht
Fristen für Ausländer bis zur
Einbürgerung sollen verkürzt Hürden
gesenkt doppelte Staatsbürgerschaft
erlaubt werden die Union als
Opposition spricht von verramchung der
deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft aber auch
Teile der FDP die moment mal in der
Regierung ist stellt sich gegen den
Entwurf der Regierung der nächste
koalitionskraft zeichnet sich ab Lars
Bohnsack aus Berlin
es ist fast genau ein Jahr her als die
Herren Scholz Harbeck und Lindner den
Koalitionsvertrag vorstellten auf 144
Seiten machte die Ampel klar dass sie
mehr Fortschritt Wagen wolle dazu gehöre
auch ein modernes staatsangehörigenrecht
daran hält der Kanzler auch heute fest
wer auf Dauer hier lebt und arbeitet der
soll auch wählen und gewählt werden
können der soll Teil unseres Landes sein
mit allen Rechten und Pflichten die
dazugehören und zwar völlig unabhängig
von Herkunft Hautfarbe oder religiösen
Bekenntnis geplant ist dass die
einbürgerungsfrist von 8 auf 5 Jahre
verkürzt wird nicht mehr die Aufgabe der
bisherigen Staatsbürgerschaft verlangt
wird und über 67-Jährige nur noch
mündliche Kenntnisse der deutschen
Sprache nachweisen müssen seit Tagen
läuft die Union dagegen Sturm es kann zu
gesellschaftlichen Spannungen führen
wenn man die Staatsbürgerschaft relativ
einfach innerhalb eines relativ kurzen
Zeitfensters bekommt wenn man vielleicht
auch die Mehrstaatlichkeit zulässt weil
habe ich da nicht entscheiden muss will
ich wirklich Staatsbürger dieses Landes
werden und das kann zu
gesellschaftlichen Spannungen führen
überraschender als der Widerstand der
Union ist aber die Tatsache dass auch
der Generalsekretär der FDP mit
ähnlichen Argumenten die Reform ablehnt
Koalitionsvertrag hin oder her die
Einbürgerung ist nur eine Fassade aber
es gehört genauso dazu dass wir bei dem
Thema Steuerung von Einwanderung aber
auch bei Themen wie Rückführung
Rückführungen definitiv besser werden
und ich finde diese Maßnahmen gehören
alle zusammen das sind keine getrennte
Debatten sondern sie passen einfach alle
zusammen nach dem Bürgergeld legt sich
der fdp-generator zum zweiten Mal
innerhalb von einer Woche in der Ampel
quer die Regierungspartner reagieren
zunehmend genervt
über alles andere wenn wir natürlich
auch miteinander sprechen
da sind alle dazu miteinander eingeladen
ich möchte daran erinnern dass im
fdp-programm steht dass die einbewohner
vier Jahren erfolgen sollte Olaf Scholz
lächelt den neuen ampelswist einfach weg
seiner Innenministerin aus deren Haus
der Entwurf stammt bleibt erstmal nur
der Appell
deswegen ist es auch ja ein Bekenntnis
für eine modernen offene Gesellschaft
die wir als Ampelkoalition ja auch in
den Vordergrund gestellt haben das ist
uns dreien ja sehr wichtig und deswegen
bin ich auch sicher dass wir da das
gemeinsam jetzt auch umsetzen können es
war ein großes Versprechen des
Koalitionsvertrages das
Staatsbürgerrecht zu reformieren dieses
große Versprechen droht vom
parteipolitischen kleinen vor allem
einer ampelpartei geschreddert zu werden
und aus Berlin ist uns jetzt Christian
Dörr zugeschaltet Fraktionschef der FDP
im Bundestag Herr dür guten Abend warum
gilt für die FDP nicht mehr was im
Koalitionsvertrag steht nämlich dass
eine Einbürgerung nach fünf und in
bestimmten Fällen auch nach drei Jahren
möglich sein soll guten Abend Frau
gelinek natürlich gilt das nach wie vor
gar keine Frage wir müssen aber
Einwanderung insgesamt denken es geht
darum dass wir Einwanderung in den
deutschen Arbeitsmarkt organisieren in
Deutschland muss eben ein modernes
Einwanderungsland werden da ist ja in
den letzten Jahrzehnten vieles falsch
gelaufen wir hatten vor allen Dingen
leider Migration in die sozialen
Sicherungssystem aber wir brauchen
händeringend Arbeitskräfte und daran
muss ich auch das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht also die
Staatsbürgerschaft orientieren und das
ist unser gemeinsames Ziel in der Ampel
ich bin mir da sicher dass wir da
Übereinkommen aber man muss das Ganze
eben zusammen denken es geht um
Einwanderung in den Arbeitsmarkt und
auch im faire Chancen für diejenigen die
herkommen im FDP Wahlprogramm vom
letzten Jahr hier haben sie die SPD
sogar noch überholt irgendeiner
Einbürgerung nach vier Jahren verlangt
warum ist das jetzt nicht mehr richtig
das Programm ist gerade mein Jahr alt
das ganze wie ich eben sagte ist Teil
eines Gesamtkonzeptes es geht darum
Einwanderung in den deutschen
Arbeitsmarkt zu organisieren denn wir
merken ja ein teilen dass überall
Arbeitskräfte fehlen auf allen Ebenen
beim Bäcker um die Ecke aber noch
natürlich die IT-Fachkräfte es fehlt an
allen Ecken und Enden wie ich gerade
sagte und deswegen müssen wir das
zusammen denken wer hier gut integriert
ist in Deutschland Arbeit hat der soll
die Möglichkeit bekommen auch die
deutsche Staatsbürgerschaft zu erhalten
wer sich allerdings das will ich auch
ehrlicherweise sagen wer sich nicht
integriert sich etwas zu Schulden kommen
lässt der muss Deutschland dann auch
wieder verlassen beides gehört für mich
zusammen Deutschland muss ähnlich wie
Kanada beispielsweise die ja auch ein
sehr moderne Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht
haben muss sich wie ein modernes
Einwanderungsland benehmen und das haben
wir in der Koalition vereinbart und
daran arbeiten wir auch da ist die
Staatsbürgerschaft ein Teil aber ein
modernes Zuwanderungsrecht eben auch und
dann müssen die Rechtsgrundlagen
geschaffen werden ihr
generalsekretärserei hat gesagt der
Zeitpunkt sei Mensch für eine
Vereinfachung des
Staatsbürgerschaftsrechts warum ist eine
Zeit in der die Industrie nach Arbeits-
und Fachkräften gerade zu schreit der
falsche Zeitpunkt ja genau darum geht es
mich dass wir das jetzt schaffen und das
ist ja keine Frage des
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht zuvorderst
sondern vor allen Dingen eine Frage des
Einwanderungsrecht da müssen wir
wirklich Hürden einreißen es ist zurzeit
wahrscheinlich leichter nach Deutschland
über das asyl- und flüchtlingssystem zu
kommen als über reguläre Migration in
den Arbeitsmarkt und daran müssen wir
arbeiten das haben wir uns auch als
Ampel vorgenommen denn es geht darum den
Wohlstand in Deutschland zu erhalten und
denjenigen die hier hart mitarbeiten
wollen den eine faire Chance zu geben
und ich sage auch den den roten Teppich
auszuräumen aber diese Klarheit im
System das ist zum Einwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt geht das muss ich wieder
spielen auch in den Rechtsgrundlagen des
Bundes damit wir da die Möglichkeit
haben dann denjenigen die sich hier
integriert haben auch die
Staatsbürgerschaft zu verleihen beides
hängt miteinander zusammen aber die
Reihenfolge muss stimmen aber vermischen
sie da nicht zwei Themen denn die
Menschen die illegal einwander sind ja
nicht die die in Deutschland
eingebürgert werden sondern das sind ja
zwei verschiedene Themen illegale
Migration und ein modernes
Einwanderungsrecht ich rede gar nicht so
sehr von illegaler Migration das ist ja
noch mal eine andere Baustelle sondern
ich rede vor allen Dingen dafür dass
Deutschland darüber dass Deutschland in
der Vergangenheit jedenfalls relativ
attraktiv war für die Einwanderung über
das Asylsystem über das
flüchtlingssystem und da geht es um
Nothilfe das soll weiter gewährleistet
sein wer politisch verfolgt ist
beispielsweise oder im vor Krieg
flüchtet der muss in Deutschland auch
Zuflucht finden aber in der
Vergangenheit ist es ja so gewesen dass
ein Großteil der Menschen über dieses
System gekommen ist und nicht über die
reguläre Migration in den Arbeitsmarkt
und das müssen wir ändern wir müssen das
quasi wieder vom Kopf auf die Füße
stellen damit es endlich so funktioniert
wie in modernen Einwanderungsländern ich
denke an Kanada Neuseeland Australien
die sind uns da ein Beispiel die machen
das und daran muss man dann eben auch
das Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht also die
Krönung sozusagen die Verleihung der
deutschen Staatsbürgerschaft anknüpfen
das gehört für mich zusammen dass wir
Migration gut organisieren sehen den
Arbeitsmarkt lenken aber eben nicht
insbesondere die Migration in die
sozialen Sicherungssysteme attraktiv
machen insofern ist da viel falsch
gelaufen insbesondere unter der
unionsgeführten Vorgängerregierung und
das wollen wir als Ampel ja ändern noch
mal der Entwurf der Innenministerin hält
sich ja ziemlich genau an das was im
Koalitionsvertrag steht wenn sie sich
nun dagegen wenden dann sieht es
natürlich so aus als ob ihnen
fdp-profilierung wichtiger ist als gutes
Regieren warum brechen sie nach der
Atomkraft und dem Bürgergeld jetzt noch
einen dritten koalitionskraft vom Zaun
ja da muss ich heftig widersprechen sie
haben ja sogar gerade aus dem
Wahlprogramm der FDP zitiert es ist uns
ein Anliegen dass einbürgerungsrecht das
Staatsbürgerschaft recht mit dem
Einwanderungsrecht sozusagen
zusammenzubringen und das ist in
Deutschland bisher nicht der Fall
insbesondere diejenigen die sich
integrieren wollen die arbeiten wollen
die haben sehr schwer und die müssen das
leichter machen nach Deutschland zu
kommen und dann auch die deutsche
Staatsbürgerschaft zu erhalten oder mit
anderen Worten wenn Deutschland gut
integriert ist müssen wir hier arbeitet
der soll es leichter haben auch
Deutscher zu werden aber auf der anderen
Seite wer sich hier nicht integriert und
am Ende vielleicht sogar Recht und
Gesetz bricht der muss das Land wieder
verlassen ich glaube das ist eine
Migrationspolitik aus einem Guss daran
arbeiten wir jetzt und das
Staatsbürgerschaftsrecht ist ein Teil
dessen
wir sind gespannt Christian dürr war das
zur zwiespältigen Einschätzung der FDP
zum Thema Einbürgerung herzlichen Dank
für das Gespräch nach Berlin ich danke
Ihnen
das Gespräch haben wir vor einer Stunde
aufgezeichnet die Einbürgerung und was
Sie für eine Gesellschaft bedeutet
könnte auch ein Thema für den Ethikrat
sein das Gremium beschäftigt sich mit
nichts weniger als mit den ganz großen
Fragen des Lebens 24 Wissenschaftler und
Wissenschaftlerinnen beraten die Politik
und uns alle wie wollen wir zusammen
leben welche Regeln funktionieren was
ist richtig und was falsch in seinem
jüngsten Bericht hat sich der Ethikrat
nun um die psychische Gesundheit junger
Menschen nach der Pandemie gekümmert und
kommt zu dem Schluss dass die jungen
zwar in der coronazeit viel Rücksicht
genommen haben aber wenig von der
Gesellschaft zurückbekommen Christiane
hübscher über die Denkanstöße des
Ethikrats
Nici Brodmann aus Berlin ist selbst
einigermaßen gut durch die Pandemie
gekommen wir treffen den 17-Jährigen
während eines routinetermins beim
Kinderarzt viele in Nikis Freundeskreis
aber hat die Zeit der lockdowns und
Schulschließungen stark mitgenommen wo
ich das eigentlich nicht dachte also vor
allem jetzt bei Jungs dachte ich okay
also ich konnte ja Basketball spielen
ist alles gut aber bei meinen Kumpels
meinten dann andere doch ah ja doch wie
eine coronazeit jetzt im Nachhinein
merke ich schon eigentlich schon
deutlich schlechter als dann jetzt
momentan der Deutsche Ethikrat fordert
heute fast drei Jahre nach Beginn der
Pandemie mit Nachdruck dazu auf die
Psyche der Heranwachsenden stärker zu
beachten und übt dabei auch Selbstkritik
der integrat habe zu wenig gewarnt auch
wenn man schon früher auf die Nöte der
jungen Generation hingewiesen habe aber
das war zu spät
die Gesellschaft ist Kindern
Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen
bislang vieles schuldig geblieben und
auch wir vom deutschen Ethikrat haben
ihre Lage nicht nachdrücklich genug
beachtet nicis Kinderarzt Dr Maske
gehört zu denen die das ganze Ausmaß der
Schäden für Kinder und Jugendliche seit
Beginn von Corona live beobachten zu
wenig Bewegung dramatische
Gewichtszunahmen psychische Probleme bei
immer mehr jungen Patienten wir hätten
uns gefreut wenn der Ethikrat schon ein
bisschen früher auf uns gehört hätte wir
haben sehr frühzeitig davor gewarnt ich
denke statt eine Entschuldigung sollte
man jetzt versuchen in die Zukunft zu
schauen das ist nicht so dass man jetzt
mal schnell eine Medizin gibt und dann
geht die Adipositas Weg das wird es
nicht sein sondern wir werden damit noch
Jahre lang zu tun haben noch dazu
überlagern sich jetzt die Krisen die
Sorge ums Klima der Krieg das
überfordert erst recht die junge
Menschen zeigt eine aktuelle Studie rund
Viertel der Heranwachsenden hat
depressionserfahrung und jeder zehnte
äußert Suizidgedanken ein Drittel hat
Angst vor dem Krieg fast jeder fünfte
Jugendliche hat bereits Schulden und
gerade an den Universitäten ist die
Erinnerung an diese Zeit des Distanz
Lernens noch sehr lebendig das ich mich
schon als Studierende Person
allein gelassen gefühlt habe war auf
jeden Fall nicht der Fokus so was da die
Jugend was damit die jüngeren Leuten
passiert lässt sich jetzt auch nicht
mehr ändern ist halt scheiße gelaufen
ich glaube das Problem ist vor allen
Dingen so ein bisschen wie bekomme ich
Hilfe wie schnell auch weil ich kenne
viele Leute die sechs Monate auf dem
Platz warten der Ethikrat fordert von
der Politik mehr Hilfsangebote und
Therapieplätze zu schaffen das Corona
Trauma dürfte sich nicht wiederholen es
ist jedenfalls das Risiko da das bei der
nächsten Krise schon wieder die Kinder
Jugendlichen und jungen Erwachsenen die
ersten sind die das zu spüren kriegen in
kalten Klassenzimmern in digitalen
Universität steht zwar wählen nie wieder
dürften Kinder und Jugendliche derart
ins Hintertreffen geraten verlangt der
integrat heute für viele dieser
Generation kommt die Erkenntnis zu spät
heute ist Montag und da wird in
Ostdeutschland demonstriert es sind
nicht mehr hunderttausend Menschen die
wir hier in Zwickau auf die Straße gehen
gegen eine vermeintliche corona-diktatur
gegen Flüchtlinge oder einfach gegen die
da oben ein harter Kern aber macht
weiter besonders in Sachsen und damit
bleibt die Frage wie die Politik mit dem
lauten teils rechtsextremen Protest
umgehen soll Sachsens Ministerpräsident
Michael Kretschmer CDU hat es erst mit
Anbietern versucht jetzt setzt er auf
Abgrenzung heute mit einem Besuch auf
dem sachsensofa einer Gesprächsreihe
nach dem Motto reden statt
brüllens berichtet aus Zwickau
Peter Möckel ist der letzte Bäcker von
zwickau-keinsdorf er kämpft wie so viele
mit den hohen Energie- und
Rohstoffpreisen eigentlich hat der
Montag seinen freien Tag nun aber muss
er Überstunden schieben weil er sich
einen zweiten Bäcker nicht mehr leisten
kann die Politik müsste sich absolut mal
ins Handwerk reinversetzen wie wir hier
arbeiten und
eigentlich müssten sie sich viel mehr
ums Handwerk kümmern weil wenn es
Handwerk ausgestorben ist dann ist
absolut Feierabend Peter Möckel spricht
von einer gespaltenen Stimmung im Ort
Zwickau im Erzgebirge im Dom fanden eins
die Friedensgebete 89 statt heute ist
die AFD stärkste Kraft im Landkreis die
Menschen haben Ängste sind verunsichert
man kann sich nicht mehr so viel
erlauben und nicht mehr so viel kaufen
die sind früher war
aber nur man möchte auch gerne mit
Kindern eine Freude machen es ist eine
große Unzufriedenheit bei der
Bevölkerung anzumerken man müsste sich
von der Bevölkerung auch besser
artikulieren besser das rüberbringen die
Probleme ansprechen die Probleme
ansprechen Debatten mit Herz und Haltung
eine Initiative der beiden großen
Kirchen der Ministerpräsident hat sich
nicht lange bitten lassen als erster
Gast nimmt Michael Kretschmer auf dem
sogenannten sachsensofa Platz es ist
schwer noch ein gemeinsamen
Informationspool zu haben eine
gemeinsame Basis von den Dingen die uns
eigentlich zusammenhalten und deswegen
das persönliche Gespräch ist durch
nichts zu ersetzen Michael Kretschmer
sucht seit Jahren das Gespräch mit
seinen Sachsen mal mehr zunehmend
weniger erfolgreich heute aber mit
ausgewählten Publikum bleibt es trotz
heikler Themen ruhig warum hat Putin am
24 Februar diesen Krieg begonnen
ist es eigentlich jetzt das wichtigste
sich in die Gedankenwelt eines solchen
Verbrechers
reinzuversetzen ist sind nicht andere
Dinge viel wichtiger Dinge wie diskurs-
wenn sie das Vertrauen und der
Bevölkerung wieder zurück haben wollen
und ehrliches Gespräch und miteinander
dann ist es an der Zeit sich jetzt zu
vergeben mit dem sachsen-sofa gehen die
Veranstalter bewusst in den ländlichen
Raum Sachsens dort wo die
Unzufriedenheit besonders groß ist wir
brauchen nicht die Miesepeter wir
brauchen auch nicht die die laut
krakühlen sondern wir brauchen Menschen
die überzeugt sind und sagen wir wollen
etwas positives für dieses Land
gestalten ich bin der festen Überzeugung
wenn wir miteinander sprechen werden wir
auch miteinander Gemeinsamkeiten finden
wir werden vielleicht so manche Ängste
auch entzaubern können und gemeinsam an
der Zukunft auch im ländlichen Raum
bauen können es sind salbungsvolle Worte
Worte voller Hoffnung ob sie jedoch
draußen auf den Markt und Demo Plätzen
gehört werden ist fraglich
und hier geht es weiter mit den
Nachrichten und Gundula und die beginnen
mit dem Krieg in der Ukraine als ein
Zeichen der Solidarität mit der Ukraine
sind sieben Außenminister nordischer und
baltischer Länder nach Kiew gereist
trotz Russlands barbarischer Brutalität
werde die Ukraine gewinnen dort rechnet
das Militär mit einer neuen russischen
Angriffswelle auf die
Energieinfrastruktur in der Region Kiew
sind weiterhin 40% der Bevölkerung ohne
Strom außerdem sprach Präsident selenski
von einer sehr schwierigen Situation an
der Front und stimmte sein Land auf
einen harten Winter ein
über die Verfolgung von russischen
Kriegsverbrechen in der Ukraine beraten
die G7 Justizminister unter deutschem
Vorsitz in Berlin erklärtes Ziel ist
laut Justizminister Buschmann
Kriegsverbrecher vor Gericht zu bringen
im Brüsseler Rathaus haben
internationale Investoren über weitere
wiederaufbauhilfen für die ukrainische
Hauptstadt verhandelt Bürgermeister
Klitschko Warp per Videoschalte erneut
um Unterstützung und erhielt von der
europäischen Investmentbank 450
Millionen Euro für Aufbaumaßnahmen in
Kiew
mit Polizeieinsätzen in mehreren
europäischen Ländern und Dubai ist ein
internationales kokain-kartell
zerschlagen worden die europäische
Polizeibehörde Europol teilte mit
insgesamt sein 49 Verdächtige eines
superkartells bei ratien festgenommen
worden das schmuggelernetzwerk habe ein
Drittel des Kokainhandels in Europa
kontrolliert
zwei Tage nach dem schweren Unwetter auf
der italienischen Insel Ischia ist die
Zahl der Todesopfer auf mindestens acht
gestiegen darunter drei Kinder und ein
Baby die Suche nach weiteren vier
Vermissten geht unvermindert weiter
ebenso die Aufräumarbeiten starke
Regenfälle hatten am Samstag zu
Überschwemmungen und Erdrutschen geführt
hunderte Einwohner wurden in Sicherheit
gebracht
in den chinesischen Staatsmedien fand
sich heute kein Sterbenswort darüber was
in den letzten Tagen in den Großstädten
des Landes passiert ist spontane
Bürgerproteste nämlich in für China
unerhörtem Ausmaß Menschen gingen auf
die Straße und verlangten ein Ende des
eingesperrtseins wegen Corona sie
forderten auch den Rücktritt von Chinas
mächtigsten Mann
inzwischen schlägt das Regime zurück die
Polizei patroulliert in den Großstädten
dass sich die Bilder des Protests
überhaupt verbreiten konnten ist wohl
auch auf die Kreativität der
Demonstranten zurückzuführen die der
Zensur zumindest kurzfristig ein
Schnäppchen schlugen so posteten sie
subtile Wortspiele wie zum Beispiel das
Wort krabbenmoos das im chinesischen so
ähnlich klingt wie Rücktritt Miriam
Steiner berichtet aus Peking
ja wir wollen keine corona-tests wir
wollen essen
bei den Protesten gegen die
corona-maßnahmen in Peking rufen Sie
diesen Satz
in Los Angeles vor dem chinesischen
Konsulat ebenfalls und danken dem der
ihn geschrieben hat danke mutiger
brückenmann
es ist ein Satz von diesen Bannern kurz
vor dem Parteitag der Kommunistischen
Partei im Oktober hängt ein Mann sie an
einer Brücke in Peking auf
wird er genannt in Analogie zum tankman
der im Juni 89 zur Ikone des
freiheitskampfs auf dem Platz des
Himmlischen Friedens wurde
es ist eine neue Generation die jetzt
auf der Straße ist in der Schule haben
diese Chinesinnen und Chinesen nie etwas
über 89 gelernt und viele hier sind zu
jung um eigene Erinnerungen daran zu
haben
was sie eint sie haben die Nase voll von
lockdowns und Massentests die
wirtschaftlichen Folgen der
corona-politik treffen sie besonders
hart von den Jungen ist jeder fünfte
arbeitslos sie wollen zurück in ihr
Leben vor der Pandemie dafür trauen sie
sich sogar auf die Straße sie rufen
Freiheit und werden festgenommen
[Musik]
auch dem Bridge man ging es so seine
Banner wurden schnell abgehängt doch
seine Botschaft verbreitet sich im
ganzen Land
zum Beispiel in Toilettenkabinen einem
der wenigen Orte in China an denen es
noch keine Überwachungskameras gibt
einer erzählt uns dass er Fotos mit den
Sätzen im Bus verschickt per
airdrop-funktion anonym an andere Handys
Interview mit einem Foto sein Gesicht zu
zeigen wäre zu gefährlich
ich denke die Chinesen müssen
wachgerüttelt werden wir müssen die
Blockade der echten Informationen
durchbrechen die Great Firewall verwehrt
den Chinesen den Zugang zu echten Infos
es ist eine junge Generation die
kreative Wege findet und ihre
technischen Fähigkeiten nutzt es ist ein
Protest innerhalb der engen Grenzen der
Diktatur ihr Symbol dafür dass leere
Blatt
Corona und die Proteste gegen die
kurve-politik der chinesischen Regierung
haben Folgen auch für die deutsche
Wirtschaft Volkswagen bestätigte in
einem Werk sei die Produktion vorläufig
gestoppte Valerie Haller wie massiv sind
denn aktuell die Probleme deutscher
Unternehmen in und mit China also der
deutsche Industrie und handelskammertag
spricht von einer großen Belastung für
die Unternehmen in China einige können
aufgrund der lockdowns nur eingeschränkt
produzieren Mitarbeiter kommen nicht zur
Arbeit weil sie daheim im Lockdown
sitzen vor Produkte fehlen weil
inländische Lieferketten nicht
funktionieren ja und teilweise müssen
Unternehmen auch tatsächlich kurzfristig
die Produktion runterfahren so wie eben
Volkswagen in einem Werk komplett in
einem anderen teilweise anderes Beispiel
Apple seit Wochen protestieren
Mitarbeiter auf dem Gelände des
Zulieferers volkskon nachdem sie
aufgrund eines lockdowns das Werk nicht
mehr verlassen durften dabei kam es
offenbar auch zu Zusammenstößen mit
Sicherheits und laut Bloomberg wird sich
dadurch die weltweite Auslieferung von
mehreren Millionen iPhones verzögern
unter dem Eindruck der Proteste gaben
auch die Börsen nach sorgen dass das
Land vor einer längeren Durststrecke
stehen könnte der DAX schließt mit einem
Prozent im Minus die Strenge
nullcovitpolitik der chinesischen
Regierung ist einer der großen
Belastungsfaktoren für die Aktienmärkte
und die globale Wirtschaft noch deutet
nichts darauf hin dass Peking seine
strengen Regeln lockert sollte sich die
Regierung aber dazu entschließen dann
könnte China als Motor für die
Weltkonjunktur wieder anspringen vielen
Dank Valerie nach Frankfurt und dazu
gibt es in unserem heute journal Update
ein Gespräch mit dem china-experten
mikoh Tari jetzt schon online auf ZDF
heute
ab 2024 sollen Väter nach der Geburt
eines Kindes die Möglichkeit für eine
zweiwöchige bezahlte Freistellung
bekommen um Zeit für die Familie zu
haben das will Bundesfamilienministerin
Pauls im nächsten Jahr gesetzlich auf
den Weg bringen die
vaterschaftsauszeit ist im
Koalitionsvertrag vereinbart und zudem
setzt Deutschland damit eine
EU-Richtlinie um
wir haben noch die wm-ergebnisse des
Tages da hat in der Gruppe H Portugal
gerade eben Uruguay besiegt 2:0 und sich
damit vorzeitig für das Achtelfinale
qualifiziert ebenfalls in Gruppe H
verlor Südkorea gegen Ghana zwei zu drei
in Gruppe G trennten sich Kamerun und
Serbien Unentschieden drei zu drei und
Brasilien gewann gegen die Schweiz 1:0
und steht ebenfalls im Achtelfinale
Erleichterung das ist wohl das Gefühl
dass heute aus Katha zu uns
herüberschwappt die Deutschen sind bei
der Fußball-WM noch nicht ausgeschieden
und sie haben sogar gut gespielt dass
eine deutsche Mannschaft seit 1934 noch
nie in dieser Phase des Turniers mit
einem Punkt so schlecht da stand ist
auch schon egal das Unentschieden von
gestern fühlt sich an wie ein Sieg Nils
Karben über den Tag danach
noch geht die katarische Sonne jeden
Morgen auf für die deutsche Mannschaft
die Tore des mannschaftshotels dagegen
blieben heute zu nur die Familien
durften kommen und die beiden Co-Trainer
gucken für eine Pressekonferenz kurz vor
die Tür
drinnen standen für die Spieler vor
allem Entspannung und Erholung auf dem
Tagesprogramm war schließlich
anstrengend gestern für mich war das
wirklich ein richtiges tolles
Fußballspiel gegen den überragenden
Gegner wo mir wirklich naja ganz
herausragende Leistung abgeliefert haben
und da ist natürlich die Freude
riesengroß in schönster wüstenkulisse
hat sich einer ganz besonders in die
Herzen von Mannschaft und Zuschauern
gespielt der Bremer Niklas Füllkrug sein
Treffer zum eins zu eins Ausgleich gegen
Spanien in der 83 Minute lässt die
DFB-Elf weiter vom Achtelfinale Träumen
es ist schon sein zweites Tor in das
dritten Länderspiel und vorerst
natürlich das Wichtigste ganz wichtig
dass wir eben einen guten Gefühl
wegfahren das war einfach ja so ein Tor
am Ende zum Ausgleich ist ja dann doch
immer ein bisschen mehr als nur ein
ausgleichsforum Gefühle vom Neuling zum
Hoffnungsträger so schnell geht das
manchmal
wir sind absoluter Teamleader trotzdem
dass er zum ersten Mals dabei ist geht
er voran er pusht die Jungs er ist
einfach kommunikativ erbringt sich voll
mit ein er hat Überlegungen er tut der
Mannschaft einfach gut ergibt viel
Energie rein die deutschen defensiv
Probleme sind seit gestern zwar eine
Nummer kleiner aber noch längst nicht
weg die Gespräche vor dem entscheidenden
letzten Gruppenspiel am Donnerstag
dürften sich allerdings vor allem ums
Tore schießen drehen noch drei solche
Sonnenuntergänge hier dann werden wir es
erleben
und am Donnerstag wird dann weiter
gezittert wir empfehlen Ihnen derweil
den spannenden montagskino Thriller
Verblendung von stiglasern und um 0 Uhr
meldet sich Nazan göktemir mit unserem
heute-journal Update das war es von uns
tschüss und einen schönen Abend bis
morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend über dem westlichen
Mittelmeer hat sich heute mal wieder ein
Unwetter tief entwickelt und dieses Tief
wird weiter Richtung Südosten ziehen für
uns sind Mitteleuropa sind aber
spannender diese hoch sie das eine im
Nordosten und das andere über den
Südwesten denn von der iberischen
Halbinsel versucht dieses Hoch morgen
eine Brücke aufzubauen zu dem hoch über
dem Nordosten das wird allerdings nicht
klappen und so wird das Wetter bei uns
sich im Wesentlichen überhaupt nicht
ändern es gibt also nach wie vor viele
Wolken und das hat auch Vorteile die
Nachttemperaturen sinken nicht so stark
ab heute Nacht erwarten wir Werte
zwischen sieben Grad am Niederrhein und
minus ein Grad in der Oberpfalz das wird
eine trübe Nacht hin und wieder auch mit
dichten Nebel es gibt etwas Regen in
Norddeutschland und am Alpenrand oder
auch in Niederbayern kann auch mal eine
Schneeflocke dabei sein das wird ein
sehr drüber Dienstag morgen ebenfalls
mit ganz wenig Regen hier im Norden das
ist meist nur Sprühregen Nieselregen
genauso wie hier im Süden da fällt der
Regen etwas stärker aus einem Alpenrand
kann auch meine Schneeflocke dabei sein
die Temperaturen liegen morgen bei vier
Grad hier in der Oberpfalz oder auch an
der Ostsee und zehn Grad am Niederrhein
und dann wird es von Tag zu Tag hier von
Osten her immer kälter am Samstag
erwarten uns dann nur noch
Höchsttemperaturen zwischen -2 und plus
6 Grad dabei wird es am Oberrhein am
mildesten und es wird von Osten nicht
nur kälter sondern auch von Tag zu Tag
etwas sonniger mit diesen Aussichten
wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt einen schönen
Abend noch wir sehen uns